what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel and feel free to
subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
okay so following the events of house of
M as we had talked about the mutant
population was at an all-time low and it
was 198 somewhere along those lines I
want to say that later on Marvel
basically adjusted the number to like
300 or something along those lines but
the fact remains it's pretty low like
it's much much lower than it was before
up but the question a lot of people had
is where do you go from here
specifically egoraptor - that question
where do you go from here after the
events and half of them okay so one of
the big issues that Marvel had growing
going up in the House of M is that they
had so many x-men publications you had
astonishing x-men new x-men x-men vol Q
you had uncanny x-men you had x-force
x-factor yet all different kinds of
things that we're going on and so what
Marvel did is they use the post house of
M landscape and decimation to
consolidate the number down because you
just really couldn't have x-factor you
know I guess you could but X Factor
wasn't as good I mean it was basically
like multiple man's investigation thing
it was like an is like an excellent
investigative team working out of mutant
town I mean it wasn't really that great
of a story was interesting but it wasn't
wildly good but the cool thing is what
Marvel did is they basically launched
the whole litany of miniseries and so
you still had the main x-men line of
publications but for the most part they
were condensed down to a pretty small
number I mean you had like x-men which
basically followed the main x-men roster
after the events of house of M you had
uncanny x-men which kind of followed
Rachel summers Marvel Girl whatever you
want to call it and then you had new
x-men and new x-men was basically
dealing with like the younger generation
of mutants but it coincided with the
origin and introduction of x-23 into the
Marvel Universe but in terms of
following like the chronological order
of x-men the mini series are really
where you go like you read like what
we're going to do in this video
decimation the day after or whatever you
want to call it and then you go into
like Messiah Complex and then you go
into Messiah War and then you go into
like utopia nation X the crochet Second
Coming revelations
you know generation hope you go into
like all these little mini series that
are designed to basically focus on what
the x-men are doing after the number had
been reduced and what leads into
basically Hope Summers the first mutant
born after the events of the House of M
now getting into decimation the day
after what this does is again this word
just kind of picks up with how the
world's reacted because with the
epilogue it's a house of them it was
just kind of like the immediate
aftermath like within the first 20
minutes of the house of them basically
ending and what people were doing what
this does is it shows us the rest of the
world in addition to the x-men so it's
actually really kind of cool but
remember within within Marvel Comics you
have a place called mutant town and
mutant town was basically like the poor
realm of where mutant stayed a lot of
villains stay there there's really just
like a poorer place and you have those
in Marvel Comics for example you have
like alphabet city which is a really
poor part of New York you just have
these little areas here and there where
Newton's congregate you have the
Morlocks down below in the in the city
I'm sorry the sewers of New York but the
idea here is that with so many mutants
losing their powers it's absolute panic
a lot of people are really just starting
to freak out over what's happening
because no one really knows what the
source of this is and no one really
knows how to deal with this not only
that there have their really like a lot
of a lot of people who are kind of
capitalizing on this in a sense that a
lot of individuals a lot of anti mutant
people out there in groups are using
this as a way to basically target
whatever mutants are left and that was
one of the interesting things about this
because it really presented like the
best opportunity right I mean prior to
the events of house of M mutants
numbered in the millions some of whom
sort of whom's powers were first
manifesting some of them had their
powers for quite some time but with the
number reduced down so low all the
anti-mutant groups and individuals
Friends of humanity and so on and so
forth they're all sitting around and
saying this is our best chance to wipe
the mutant scourge from the planet
forever we're never going to get another
opportunity better than this because
it's easier to take out 198 mutants than
it is to take out millions of mutants
and so from here we basically take up
with the x-men themselves again you know
Cyclops Emma Frost so on and so forth
and it's basically them just kind of
analyzing the entire situation now what
Cyclops does is he basically invokes the
abilities of a woman main stage and
we've never really talked about sage
before this because we didn't need to
there was never a good reason to talk
about him she was a she's that she's
minor but she has a really really cool
powers sages mind it's basically a
computer it offered to the exact same
capacity as a computer does so where you
sit down and you say okay I've got five
things I need to do today I need to
clean the house and I need to go grocery
shopping and I need to buy some new
clothes buy some new shoes and I need
to clean the color like you'd be able to
keep those things relatively organized
but you may struggle here in there sage
doesn't have that problem sage can keep
her mind perfectly organized not only
that she can take in a massive amount of
data and organize it and construct it
becomes to the best kind of conclusion
on what the data represents so she's
literally a living computer but her
powers make her essential to the x-men
figuring this out because what she can
do is she can listen to all the news
broadcast she can analyze all the data
she sees on the internet she can access
all these different sources of
information and she can basically break
them down on their most fundamental
level and come to a conclusion on what
the most likely source of this is as
well as what number of mutants are left
within the realm of Marvel Comics that
still have their powers because keep in
mind almost no one except for those
individuals who are part of House of M
and retain their memories almost no one
knows that the Scarlet Witch did this
and so for Emma Frost and Cyclops
they're kind of walking in this weird
situation because on one half they can
take like Scarlet Witch did it Scarlet
Witch is the reason why this happened
but on the other hand if they do and
people learn all this happened because
there's one mutant that has the ability
to work reality on such a scale that
they can change the entire landscape of
the planet Earth
well then suddenly those remaining 198
mutants become a credible threat because
now they're basically wolves backed into
a corner and the idea is that one of
them may lash out and they may end up
you know screwing things up worse than
they are now and so for the sake of
making sure the government isn't just
throw them all in internment camps Emma
Frost with Cyclops as well as those
others who know about what's going on
aren't telling his soul and so what we
do is we pick up at the Pentagon with a
woman named Valerie Cooper now Valerie
Cooper dates back to the 1990s really
maybe even before that and she operated
as part of x-factor now what I want is
what I want to throw in here for a
second is how x-factor function and
their original iteration under Louise
Simonson and Walter Simonson x-factor
was the continuation of the original
x-men team remember when Chris Claremont
took over the x-men title in 1975 and
launched I guess the second version of
the team called uncanny x-men it was a
whole new roster you know yet Wolverine
he had a colossus mike golic
so on and so forth and it changed a
dynamic and the stories were really
really good well what Marvel did is they
launched x-factor which was the original
x-men Cyclops beast
Iceman gene and Angel and gave them
their own team the two operated side by
sides but they had different goals where
Charles Xavier whole idea of having
Xavier Institute's to Train mutants to
use their power was still very much a
part of his whole of a whole x-men
franchise what x-factor it was it was
the original x-men masquerading as
mutant hunters and then grabbing those
mutants and taking them to the Xavier
Institute to the humanity wouldn't
persecute them that was one part of
their whole thing now x-factor had their
own line of stories that's where you ran
into like the introduction of Apocalypse
and it was really really cool you know
to see a lot of those things begin to
unfold by going from the I guess from
the time of the x-men team was kind of
rolled over I guess x-factor in the
traditional x-men were rolled over into
a singular team The X Factor concepts
continues except it was basically a
government-sanctioned superhero team and
that's where you got into the idea of
like Polaris haddock a strong guy those
that that particular roster of X Factor
but in order to have them operate with
the government that was a liaison and
there were a couple of them one of them
was forged and then another one was
Valerie Cooper and I want to say the
Valerie Cooper came after forge but the
idea here is that she's basically a
liaison to the mutant population and
what we find out by virtue of her
meeting with the Pentagon is that the
office of national emergency has been
mobilized now the office of national
emergency is exactly what it sounds like
it's literally just an office of
national emergency it's designed to
respond in times of crisis so think of
it as like a Marvel Comics version of
FEMA the difference here is that the
office of national emergency the
military branch has been mobilized for
the purpose of basically locking down
mutants for responding to the mutant
threat on a global scale and so well it
doesn't mean they're going to be taking
mutants into like internment camps it
doesn't mean they're going to serve as
somewhat of both a jailer and a a
protector in the sense that mutants are
really going to be allowed to leave but
no one can come in and hurt them anyway
so it kind of puts mutants in a state of
flux and what this was but Marvel
basically taking a mutant population
sitting it down taking the x-men sitting
them down and saying okay we're
basically just going to kind of keep
them here until we can figure out what
to do next we just keep in mind Marvel
had Civil War coming down the pipe and
so the idea was one was focusing on
Civil War and then going into the
aftermath to the death of Captain
America the initiative and so on and so
forth and then going into the x-men
stories following all that stuff that
followed out and so again you know
picking up with this fallout with this
response it's really just kind of
Cyclops reaching out to almost everyone
he can because remember because of
attractive the Xavier Institute was such
a former part of the x-men universe and
because almost everybody out there who's
associated with the x-men was in some
form
fashion part of the Xavier Institute in
the first place it's basically Cyclops
and the excellent operating as this
central hub they're reaching out to
everybody they reach out to Jamie Matt
rocks multiple men who of course is one
of the people that maintain his
abilities but is also Emma cross dealing
with the fallout of this in the sense
that it's everything that they fought
for is come crashing down the entire
basis behind the Xavier Institute was to
give mutants a safe place but if there's
no Xavier Institute there's no reason
for them to be there now again this sets
the stage for things to come for example
will actually pick up later on where the
story called utopia and utopia actually
takes place during Dark Reign when
Norman Osborn's becomes director of
shield after Tony Stark is kicked out
following the events of a civil war and
Secret Invasion and that leads into the
excellent basically abandoning the
continental United States taking up
residence on an island off the coast of
San Francisco and then shutting down the
Xavier Institute so it kind of kind of
gets into a cool situation here but the
idea is that again it's really everybody
just kind of panicking but not everyone
used things the same way keep in mind
that storm is still with with black
panther at the moment their relationship
is still as strong as it ever was
and it's actually leading up to their
marriage during the events of civil war
but with storm staying and Wakanda he
basically tells Cyclops look this is a
global issue this is not a you know
Westchester new New York issue you
should basically kind of spread your
forces around now there are benefits but
there's drawbacks to this so this is one
of the things that makes it kind of cool
it's because for store and she's like
look you should have mutants you know
x-men everywhere trying to assess the
threat on a global scale but for Cyclops
there's so few of them left if they were
to spread their forces out too thin all
they do is make themselves targets it's
a lot easier to eliminate 15 mutants
across ten different countries than it
is to take out 198 mutants or 150
mutants in one single location and so
really it's kind of the situation where
the Cyclops recognizes the value of her
argument but at the end of the day he
can't bring himself to do it so again we
just kind of go through this quick
little rundown on different mutants that
have lost their powers of course
Magneto's basically a homeless guy just
kind of sitting on the street muttering
to himself about how he always wanted to
do the right thing
Jubilee doesn't have her powers anymore
she's lost her abilities she actually
gets a call from Wolverine checking up
on her to see how it is that she's doing
because remember their relationship
really kind of dates back to the to the
earlier days when she first joined x-men
going into Generation X and so on and so
forth or at least their friendship
anyway but from here it really kind of
jumps to like Colossus and
of course you learn Colossus still has
his powers and that's one of the things
that I hope you guys notice here when it
comes to the mutants who maintain their
abilities and emitting to lost their
abilities the ones who remain who kept
their powers are for the most part the
most popular ones nobody wants to read a
story about flawed cause where he
doesn't have any powers people want to
read stories about Cyclops where he's
able to blow holes and walls and
different things like that it always
makes things kind of cool the same thing
with Colossus not only that keep in mind
this comes out of astonishing x-men so
where Colossus died in 1997 I think it
was when the legacy virus was killing
mutants all over the place and someone
had to ingest it sacrificed their life
so a cure could be made Colossus was
brought back by Joss Whedon during the
first run I think of astonishing x-men
so it wouldn't make any sense to kill
him off in 1997 bring him back in 2004
and then take away his powers in the
same year it wouldn't make any sense to
do that
Dan's would have been pissed because so
many things are so hyped to see him
return but what we're also seeing here
is the fact that there are a lot of
mutants out there who viewed the Xavier
Institute as a safe haven now what this
does it's set up the stage for the 198th
and what this does is basically kind of
turn the Xavier Institute into this
place where everybody can take up refuge
it's one of the reasons why if you guys
start going through when you just kind
of glimpse older comics coming out of
decimation where it's like there's all
these mutants that are seeing if you
save your Institute that's what it turns
into
so I crops turns the place into a safe
haven where it's like if you're one of
the remaining 198 mutants that are out
there come to the Xavier Institute and
we'll keep you safe now of course one of
the things that it also shows us is that
there are individuals who are hunting
mutants down and trying to eliminate
them now of course Wolverine and
Colossus jump into the fray they save a
handful of these Morlocks some of the
individuals who are trying to keep
themselves safe but as this begins to
wrap up this leads into this joint
venture whereby we basically have these
signals under the control of the office
of national emergency arriving at the
Xavier Institute again they turn into
jailers as well as protectors in the
sense that they're there to make sure
that no one can attack the x-men but it
is a grudging alliance the x-men don't
want to feel like they're prisoners and
while they look at the signals as
protectors they also look at them as
jailers you notice it was like no one
comes
no one goes this place is basically a
black hole on the planet Earth this is a
refuge for mutants you can't leave but
you can't come in it creates kind of an
interesting situation and so this is why
Cyclops or one of the reasons why he
turns the Xavier Institute into a refuge
he says they look we just got to kind of
get you know we got to deal with the
hand that's dealt
and in the end if they're here to
protect us and to make sure that no one
can get in or get out then the very
least don't let what remains of the
mutant population end but no humans will
be allowed to get in here now at this
point things begin to kind of start a
spiral out into many series that's why
this is kind of like a catapult it
really kind of sets things in motion
with regards to what comes next and so
what Marvel did at least the next major
story they did with something called
x-men deadly Genesis which is an amazing
story but deadly Genesis literally goes
back through and one it sees the return
of Charles Xavier and two it actually
introduces Vulcan the third Summers
brother this omega-level mutant that
actually becomes a major character going
into war of kings and realm of kings I
think it was but it's really kind of
cool but in this also jumps into
Wolverine Origins and endings which is
what we're cover but again there were a
lot of mini-series here I mean it sets
the stage for Generation M which is
basically Generation X it deals with
kind of like a reimagining of Generation
X a lot of those forgotten characters in
terms of what their powers are able to
do or at least what powers they have
whether they still have them or not
x-factor Jimmy mad rocks whole whole
idea with being part of like the like an
investigative group tracking down
mutants who still have their powers kind
of helping them get to the Xavier
Institute son of M which is actually
really really cool it's basically
Quicksilver trying to restore mutant
powers and he actually steals the
carriage and crystals from Attilan which
is kind of funny and it backs fire it
backfires in the extreme but it's really
kind of cool again these are a lot of
the many series of are coming down the
pipe those regards to City to the x-men
franchise but if the guys are nil here
to come in to explain make sure you hit
the sub button to become part of the rod
for you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and yeah leave a
comment down below because I'm kind of
curious is this helping you guys
understand because the whole basis
behind this is one because I think it's
interesting I don't really see it as
something that I want to be insanely
popular I mean it's cool if it is but
this is really just designed to kind of
help answer questions that you guys have
with regards to what's going on with the
x-men after the events of house to them
where do you know where you go after the
events of house of M and the things that
take place leading up to all-new
all-different marvel with regards to the
x-men themselves but let me know down in
the comments if this helps you guys at
all hopefully it does and yeah I'll
catch you all later please
[Music]
you